more than a century this monument for
fallen German soldiers stood undisturbed
in the heart of the coastal town of
swakopmund in Namibia but local hero
activists want to get rid of this
monument as soon as possible we want
this monument to be removed and it must
be sent back to Germany activists
recently covered the monument with red
paint to symbolize the blood that was
spilled here between 1904 and 1908
German colonial forces put down an
operating of local Herero and nama
minorities against the German push for
land about 80% of all Herrero are
believed to have been killed what's
written in German is with the help of
God and for Emperor and Empire were
fighting the members of the marine
expedition in the following battles and
they see a whole list of battles from
1904 where the Germans should stop were
involved fighting the Herero and nama
people but nowhere here is made mention
of the tens of thousands of Herero and
nama people who subsequently died in
these battles but German tourists don't
understand why the Herero would want the
monument gone it's actually very stupid
because this is also their history and
it's a warning so it won't be war again
thousands of tourists flocked to this
coastal town every year even local hero
craftsmen's are concerned about losing
their German customers it said as you
see also it had us busy but you see dead
one is them there is people from Germany
it's very spot of history you see they
come here you see they come to see did
moment from the history that's what we
are selling our tourists here as the
past and this cologne or this the style
of sacrament which I think we've got a
great success of swakopmund was the site
of one of the five concentration camps
the German colonizers put up to imprison
the local population as documented by
German authorities none survived longer
than 10 months the skulls of the dead
were sent to Berlin for racial studies
yet very little evidence of this history
can
we found that the local cemetery and
here they also put the monument here
which says that the Harrow people died
under mysterious circumstances these
words it makes me very painful
mysterious circumstances we know the
cause of death of our people look at
those unmarked graves
thousands and thousands and thousands a
monument that was put up by the hero
themselves had to be partly destroyed
after complaints from the German
community living in the houses
overlooking the graveyard on top of that
there was this the scar from Hal Roach
the later or chief it's no longer there
because the German community which he
was staying next to those great yet they
were they said that that horn was
actually our funding in offending yeah
this car was actually offending them in
Namibia a battle for the memory of the
colonial history is taking place more
than a century later the wounds have
still not healed